just so you guys know uh whenever we
post the two view in regards to anything
upcoming film a show anything on our
website you both get the most views ever
when it comes to etcanada.com uh so the
fact that you're both in this movie
together the fact that you're in this
interview our fans are going to lose it
anything you want to say to your fans
relax
[Laughter]
now we have to give a good interview
that's a lot of pressure
well you don't have to do anything just
sitting there together is good enough
for people um you know with both of you
being a part of you know of course uh
katrina the biggest like tv series jamie
of course these huge films um
jamie had you seen outlander before
working with champ
[Laughter]
eight years of my career has been
reduced it means no listen i'm sure it's
great i have three small kids i don't
have time for
you're not exactly the demographic i
think it's okay all right i'm too old so
what you're saying yeah okay listen i
will if i find myself uh you know up in
the mountains of canada filming or
something about a decent wi-fi i'll i'll
i'll give outlander go ah
i didn't mean to throw you under the bus
i'm sorry
but i have to ask
i have to ask you trina have you seen 50
shades of grey any of the films
no look at this
you guys
we're very we're very supportive of each
other in in our own way just uh not with
our word
this is now my new favorite interview
just like some of you that i would be
working with in one day so i didn't want
to color the experience with having too
much
of another character in my head just
right that's a good answer that's that's
the safe answer that's good um okay well
let's talk about belfast listen this is
such a great film you both are so
phenomenal in this um of course there's
such a standout moment jamie when you're
singing uh to katrina and that in that
scene it's so good were you singing live
i know i recorded it after thankfully
because that's a huge extra stress that
i didn't have on the day um
but yeah i mean there was a sort of
magic day that you know it was really
special
pretty much everyone bar one uh actor i
don't want to say that wasn't cause it
ruined something i wasn't there for
obvious reasons but um you know just to
have all of us in the room like that it
felt special it's such a joyous
brilliant it's a brilliant pop song that
yeah this one was just giving me stacks
back and and we had to get through this
dance that we've been rehearsing a lot
so it was a lot of uh pressure but it
was a great day it was good fun
it was such a great scene um before i
have to leave um i just want to say
congratulations on your your baby boy
jamie obviously a father of three kids
did you have you given her any parenting
advice i don't think you could have
actually given me a weekend yeah yeah
um not relevant but um
it's a modest thing you know so i find
it so crazy that you know like you just
you played this you're so brilliant in
this movie and you played a mother and
you weren't and now here we are sitting
here and you are it's kind of my house
isn't it yeah it feels like two days ago
that we showed the movie i know i mean
it's it's a lot has happened in the last
year
you